If you're willing to discuss this, this would a good topic on the discussion
boards. Many of us have been exposed to token economies. I remember being
exposed to a token economy in elementary school, where we earned stars for
every book that we read. And at the end of the semester, we could trade those
stars in for all types of valuable toys and activities. Also parents use token
economies quite often with their children. When they try to get them to do
their homework, to brush their teeth or make their bed. So, for example, a
child can earn a star for every day of the week that they make their bed. And
at the end of the week, those stars can be traded in for activities such us
video game playing or perhaps even earning money to buy a new toy. Finally, if
any of you have ever watched the show Super Nanny, you have seen her put token
economies to excellent use in trying to manage child behavior.